Oh Oh yuck it really stays at you I'm
Sam and I am a nail-biter an ex and I'm
pretty much a lifetime nail-biter
I started biting my nails because my
brother bit his nails when I was a kid
and I thought it was really cool and
then I just couldn't stop I've invited
my nails forever I'm a musician so the
thing I'm always trying to avoid is
biting my fingernails that they hurt
when I press down on things like the
keyboard or guitar things have gotten
pretty desperate and that's why we turn
to you the BuzzFeed community to tell us
how to stop so I guess I'm definitely
not the worst at this game nervous no
it's probably one of those things that
tastes really bad I've just bitten
through that exercise I exercise
okay putting band-aids on my nails
helped yes snow and white snow and white
17 honestly I play with silly putty
while I'm nervous and it really helps I
would play with silly putty we read all
of your responses and we're gonna try 5
ways to stop biting your nails
pigeon spinners for fission toys silly
putty we're going to try the band-aids
Melvindale whatever makes your nails
taste that
and then lastly well I'm gonna get an
acrylic manicure I will not we're gonna
do five days of this during the work
week when you're stressed so if we start
to see some improvement that will at
least be an indication that there is
hope the games begin now day one of the
stop biting your nails challenge today I
have to put band-aids on my fingers and
I'm on my way to a trivia night so
that's gonna be socially acceptable the
band-aids so far are not the worst but
as much as I like them when I put them
on I cannot use a cell phone typing is
not very easy either so the band aid has
been inconvenient but
have not hit my nails yet I'm here
watching Sam put this nail polish on
over her over my dry brittle disgusting
fingers probably I don't know how this
works
no one I'm dreading is the fact that in
order to see whether this is working I'm
gonna have to taste it okay that's
disgusting yeah she's did so many bad
like herbal teas in my life this could
be one of them I'm still not recovered
so this Melville's stop is ruin my
afternoon because there's this really
nice you know bit of fruit here
I really can't touch a piece of it I'm
about to go bobbing for apples into this
thing and just deep in my face it's been
six hours since I put it on and it
actually stopped me from biting so
there's hope this is day three of my
attempt to stop biting my nails the mo
lova stop lavalla stop i don't know how
to pronounce that it is still working I
like my finger right now yeah it's still
gross but this morning I'm glad that my
tool is a fidget cue I forgot my
headphones and already this is my new
favorite toy and my favorite way of
distract with myself today I'm trying
this fidget ring you can see it it likes
pins we're gonna see how that works
having an excellent time with this toy I
think I'm still picking out my nails I
didn't really use it but I'll tell you
what I did do I didn't accidentally lick
my fingers near my mouth even when I was
like eating things my hands and the
mavala stop is still on honestly
the bad tasting nail polish might work
right now we're on the way to get my
second manicure ever
I had a bunch but I've never had a gel
manicure before if I feel like if I kind
of have nice
that have been treated well like maybe I
will continue to treat them well I
always get mocked at the man and carrots
cut my nails are so short I'm expecting
more of the same on the way out of the
nail salon how'd that go for you
it was so well my stomach Bhaduri God
just hates the nail polish doesn't work
but I will give it a different way I can
keep the manicure on for more than two
weeks and make like a long-term
lifestyle change because let me tell you
how good it feels to see your name in
alternative today I have silly putty I
have not seen this in about 20 years
okay is that what you're playing with
back there you bite your nails too right
yes do you think it would stop you from
biting your nails though no I'm
optimistic because so far the thing to
help most was the distracting band-aid
so I don't know maybe having a little
fidgety toy will be puppies this is
going well I don't think I'm getting the
urge to bite my nails because I still
have nail polish on them but we'll uh
we'll see on a positive note the silly
putty can bounce which is pretty fun if
I could catch it we are finished with
our five-day experiment to stop biting
your nails I feel like I have been a
little bit tormented gonna lie I kind of
relapsed in a meeting yesterday yeah I
mean I clearly haven't stopped I'm not
looking too good right now it was a good
experiment to see just how much I've
been tempted my most successful day was
the first day I'm gonna try to ban it
again it was helpful and the only thing
were you literally couldn't do anything
about it my most successful day would
have had to have been the gel manicure
as hellish as the experience actually
was because manicures are bullies it is
really a deterrent to have this really
strong shellacked nail that you can't
just you know
thanks so much the aesthetic Pepper for
the suggestion for the band-aids
every time I wear them that's terrifying
and thank you to cat lady with a series
of numbers after it for recommending the
gel manicure I really hope this is the
long-lasting solution if anyone knows a
manicure is nice enough to not shave me
for my tiny nails hit a girl up don't
forget to bookmark this video and check
back in in five years we'll we'll do a
follow up we're gonna do the reunion
tour that's a lot of no fingers left
because they bit
[Music]